Brittney's with us in washington DC hey
Brittany how are you happy new year
happy New Year to you how can I help
because I just got your books in
December thank God unless the came down
from heaven heard you were gonna help me
change my whole life but my boyfriend
wants to help me with my pan down the
debt and I kind of feel guilty for
having them help me because he was
really smart and you know decided at a
young age he didn't never want to have
any debt so he doesn't have any and I
feel bad that his money is going towards
my debt and then he has to be on the
budget and everything when you know he's
not the one who has the issue by helping
you you mean he's giving you some of his
money he basically does give me all the
money he's like here you go use this or
whatever we need to take care of okay
no I would not do that under any
circumstances and here's what here's why
now as soon as you're married if you get
married someday I would do then you know
at that point you're married and you you
treat that as one and so you take care
of each other and yes you would accept
whatever help from your husband or he
would accept whatever help from his wife
that you need to so when you're married
that's fine but when your
boyfriend/girlfriend that's really
dangerous because I mean it could get
really really messy if there was a
breakup and if there's not a breakup it
still changes the tenor the sense of the
relationship doesn't it yes because I've
always been an independent one so I've
always you know I'm not the best as I
found out after reading your books but
I've always taken care of myself and had
my own condo so accepting this helping
him is really really hard for me yeah I
would not I would accept him being your
cheerleader your advisor you know giving
you some guidance because he's good at
handling money but I would not suggest
that he give you money or you accept
money until you're married now if you
set a date and you come home from the
honeymoon
then the whole thing changes then
everything is combined everything is
combined and it doesn't matter who
brings what you could be he could be
dirt poor and you could be really rich
but you got married now we are really
rich right that's how it works but but
not not until we're married because it
just changes you know you know this
already because just talking about it
made you feel weird yeah so you know
it's gonna change things and he's being
nice he does he's not thinking about it
creating weirdness but it's gonna create
weirdness kiddo and I I don't think
it'll be good for your relationship and
he's not doing it to try to be
manipulative that's not who this guy is
not the way you described him anyway and
and you're not doing it to be you're not
not accepting it to be weird or
something it's just until you're married
you should not share assets you will get
and/or liabilities you will get yourself
in a real mess real mess so just if this
leads to marriage later then we can have
the discussion after the honeymoon yeah
I'm gonna combine everything everything
at that point so a good question